all of us who work in the world of film
acting are still anxious when we're
faced with real-life drama the drum roll
so to speak there are no retakes tonight
there are no rehearsals to prepare for
that singular moment when the envelope
is opened the name inside will certainly
change one actor's life as it changed
mine last year as a messenger Pierre and
movie lover I stand here tonight to tell
you five nominees the best news of all
you have moved me moved the Academy move
the people your performances took us
somewhere we have never been somewhere
strange and familiar and we are changed
forever by that glimpse that moment that
intimacy in that surrender all of it
itched in celluloid the Academy thanks
you this year's nominees for Best
Performance by an actor in a leading
role the nominees are Kenneth Branagh
for Henry v Tom Cruise Tom Cruise were
born on the 4th of July
Daniel day-lewis for my left foot
Morgan Freeman were driving miss daisy'
Robin Williams for Dead Poets Society
and the Oscar goes to hmm Daniel
day-lewis
you've just provided me with the makings
of one hell of a weekend in Dublin
I shared Krista's life for a while with
a remarkable young actor called Hugh
O'Connor but for everyone involved in
the film all our desire to make the film
all the strength that we needed all the
pleasure that we took in making the film
came from Christy Brown when he was
alive he needed very little
encouragement to make his voice heard
now he needs a little more and I'm truly
grateful to you that in honoring me with
this award you're encouraging Christy to
carry on making his mark thank you very
much indeed